- Noah!
- Hi!
- This is such a big deal you're here.
- Thank you, thank you, I big deal.
- I mean, you are really
like such a hot shot.
Like, I don't know--
- Oh, you too.
- If it's "Stranger Things."
Oh, God, I'm tryin'.
I don't know if it's like the TikTok world
is freaking out that you're here.
- I don't know.
- The "Stranger Things" world.
And I am so exited for "Hubie Halloween."
Adam was here yesterday--
- Me too, yeah.
That's awesome, I love Adam.
He is just the best person.
- Yeah.
- Yah know, what you see is what you get.
- He's pretty great, he's hilarious too.
- He's such a kind and dear--
- He's so sweet.
I mean, just being on set with him,
he's like hilarious to be around.
I remember one night
we were like exhausted,
and everyone just wanted to go home.
And he like, brought his speaker out.
He started playing like Selena Gomez
and he just lifted the mood.
He has that effect.
- How old were you when you started?
- Started acting?
- Yeah.
- I was, oh my, I was like six or eight.
(Drew gasps)
I was young.
- So you were six, I
was six when I did E.T.
with Stephen Spielberg,
who you worked with--
- That's crazy.
I worked, that was the
first movie I ever did.
I was turning 10 on set.
I didn't even know who
they were at the time,
which is crazy to me!
'Cause they were like my idols.
And I mean yeah, I remember
them like bringing me out
and surprising me with a cake on
my 10th birthday at like midnight.
And my mom has a video on her phone.
It was pretty cool, so--
- So in some ways
both of us are very transformed
through Stephen Spielberg.
- Yeah, he's like our,
he's our middle man.
- Yes, he is!
And I, you know, my mom put me to work
when I was like in
diapers, at 11 months old.
- Oh my God.
- And I have to say,
I thank her every single day for it.
Because I love my life,
and I love the opportunities that I have.
and it's like mine--
- Me too.
- To screw up or not, you know?
- Yeah.
- But she gave
me a window and a door.
And I loved getting to be a kid that got
to live out their fantasies and dreams.
- Yeah, oh my God, it's like
a dream, this kind of life.
It's so cool.
- Can I talk to you
quickly about TikTok?
Because--
- Let's do it.
- Okay, 13 million followers.
- It's crazy.
I joined TikTok kinda like a year ago.
And it was just for fun.
And then I fell in love with it.
And sometimes I go out.
And like before TikTok, obviously,
everyone's like, "Oh,
Stranger Things," Noah."
Like, "That's you," and now
the younger kids will be like,
"Oh my God, Noah from TikTok!"
And it sits so weird to
me, like that's crazy.
But it's awesome and I love it.
- Now I'm, you know, a
parent to two daughters,
six and eight, and they live for TikTok.
- Yeah, that's that TikTok generation.
- I know, they really hook 'em.
- I mean, what do you think parents
should know about TikTok?
- I think it's my favorite one out of all
of the like socia medias.
I don't know, I feel like
a lot of them can be toxic.
And just not good for your
mental health, I guess.
And TikTok's kind of just
a relaxed, fun place to be.
- I'm so, like, happy that you came here.
I feel so lucky.
- Oh, thank you.
- You really are out there in the world.
And there's a lot of people that watch
all the things that you do.
You're a part of these really big worlds.
Like, "Stranger Things,"
and TikTok--
- You're so nice.
- And--
- So many compliments.
- It's true though.
- Thank you.
- Like, it's you know,
when you're that out there,
and you're reaching that many people,
it's always nice when it's
a really nice person too.
You know?
- Aw.
- Because--
- Well, same with you.
I mean, you're so influential,
and you're so grounded.
And this is just
compliments back and forth.
- By the way, it was a
winding road to get here.
And that's why I'm so
- Oh I know.
- Invested, you know?
Because nobody has a straight path.
We all have to figure out who
we're gonna be in this world.
And when we see, you know,
people leading a good life,
who other kids are looking
to, parents are look to.
It's like good, you're safe, you're good,
you are kind, you are talented,
and I'm so glad you're here.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Noah,
for visiting the show.
- Thank you so much
for having me.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
- Seriously, I can't wait
to see the big next epic
thing you step into.
- Thank you, thank you--
- Well, we're cheering you on.
- Thank you so much, you're the best--
- Thank you Noah.
All right, "Hubie Halloween"
is available on Netflix now.
Say that with a lisp.
(upbeat music)